joining me today is the man that I have
dubbed the Willy Wonka of politics it
even says so on the back of his book
right here Michael malice welcome back
to the Rubin report good to be back
again Dave
we have a lot to do my friend now most
of it obviously is going to have to deal
with your choice of wardrobe a general
persona and okaying you've really done
it this time jacket mint this is the
actually the same thing that Johnny Depp
or but it's a W for him now it's an M
and now it's an M for Michael although
if you flipped it upside down it would
be a W yeah for wiliness
or Willy Wonka there you go that's
actually the the one I didn't see that
well it's not I don't know one what it
is it is the better one yes you're gonna
tell me the Charlie in the Chocolate
Factory with Johnny Depp is better than
Willy Wonka the chocolate back rang with
Gene Wilder and I'm not trying to be a
contrarian not trying it if it's much
better I haven't seen it but there's no
way it's better well it's pretty good
I'm telling you how could it possibly be
better you're telling me he was better
he was better than Gene Wilder I'm in a
position to make this call I suppose at
some level because of the great honor
that I've bestowed upon you by calling
you the Willy Wonka politics but I just
I mean I just don't think anything could
possibly be better than Gene Wilder as
well watching and tweet out the answer
this is a really disturbing start to
this thing okay so let's do this so
first off I'm gonna do this interview
completely in a different way than I've
ever done oh okay is that you may notice
I have no notes here okay my policy is
that when it's a good interview I don't
have to look down once but I thought
you're so bananas your political
theories are so on out there I thought
I'm just gonna sit down and completely
see what happens I am literally not
going to write down one thing beforehand
so the reason that I call you the Willy
Wonka polish yes it's not just because
of your high fashion style yeah but you
actually do strike me as a unique
political thinker which is pretty
freakin rare these days well that's a
huge compliment thank you that's all I
have for you okay good job
so but but you really do it even the way
you tweet the way you use trolling you
know you're you're out there political
thoughts all of those things I mean the
way you present yourself it's all like
just this really bizarre package so for
people that didn't see our first integer
just give me Michael malleus 101 let's
just get the history out of the way well
then we'll go into the the new right and
the topics of the day the glib answer he
sees the boy you hate to love the longer
answer is my background is with North
Korea was my last book with your reader
the new right happened as a consequence
of so many of my friends who were in
tort roles who were anarchists fell down
these rabbit holes of what they were
what was called insomnia reaction and
later became like the alt-right and dark
enlightenment so I watched the scene
from the build up from the ground floor
and then to have it culminate to some
extent in the Trump presidency and
contemporary cultural wars
I had a bird's-eye view so I knew
someone was going to have to write a
book about the subculture and I also
knew that you know any reporter is not
going to be able to understand the scene
because at the very least there gonna be
an outsider secondary they're gonna have
their own you know prejudices so since
my job had been to make North Korea you
know before I started my North Korea
work the idea was there crazy and crazy
means I don't understand you it does it
could mean I'd understand you could mean
that you're Randa but now everyone
understands North Korea is not crazy
they have a very coherent logical
approach to their evil dictatorship and
the same thing with this scene everyone
would like to dismiss it jump ever love
everybody in they're all nuts they're
all Nazis and it we really convenient if
you could paint everyone with the same
brush they'd be a lot less efficacious
it'll be a lot easier to dismiss but
that's not the way it is and and people
understand that any subculture even the
let you know for the Republicans they
think oh the less the same the Hillary
Clinton hate the burning people they
really hate them so there's a lot of
different groups in what I call the new
right and often though they're united in
what they regard as their opposition as
a progressivism between them they do not
have much agreement okay so with that as
the backdrop to all of this and this
also explains why when BuzzFeed and
HuffPo and Vox and the rest of them are
writing about you guys whatever that
collective thing here is they always get
it all sort of wrong because as you said
they're not part
so they just look at the oh they must be
racist part well they also have an
agenda yeah so racist means that which
is against progressivism and I have a
list in the books of things that have
been called racist which includes moving
into minority neighborhoods and moving
out of mine ever in our neighborhoods
noticing races and not noticing races
milk certainly there was a dinosaurs
I mean picnics wait what type of
dinosaurs racist there was in Jurassic
Park one of the dinosaurs was called
racist I'm not sure exactly why I didn't
follow meeting through the article yeah
so I don't know and possibly what was
his name Fred Flinstones pet no Dino
yeah he's a bit of a white supremacist
being you unfortunate so I thought
someone has to write this book and also
it's it's a dark space so I wanted to
have people be able to explore it in an
interesting way and in a non-threatening
way okay so for people that know nothing
about this the the couple groups that
you just mentioned they're darked
enlightenment the troll community all of
this stuff can you just kind of break
down all of it how did this start how
did you even start caring about it were
you part of it what the hell is going on
it I wasn't even for me and I have some
basic understanding of this stuff I'm
actually not totally clear on all the
sort of markers and and where everybody
is online and all that so it starts I
ground it in 1992 when Pat Buchanan who
is regarded as a paleo conservative we
teamed up with Murray Rothbard who was
regarded as a paleo libertarian so
between those two men
you basically have everything that is
happening today within the same meaning
nationalism trolling flirting with
racism you know contempt for authority
skepticism toward the establishment the
two of them had many disagreements and
at one point you know Pat Buchanan
turned on Murray Rothbard and later he
asked Murray Rothbard
executor for forgiveness literally
getting on his knees and asked me for
forgiveness I broke that news in the
book and that has come down to
contemporary terms where the internet
what social media allows and this is
both the positive and negative is back
in the day if you were that one person
in your town with these rude fringe
views you're the Freak but now that one
person with their weird fringe views in
that
town can talk to the other person with
the rude fringe we use in the other town
or in Denmark or in Asia or can put on a
purple jacket and show up at the Rubin
report it's all very good they can't
pull it off
you have to earn this jacket so but now
they have a community and discussion and
they can develop an ideology so what I
saw happening as a result of hanging out
with the trolls is people falling into
this group called what was called at the
time neo reaction or the dark
enlightenment and it was things like we
need to return to monarchy America is
this decadent Weimar Republic that's on
the verge of destruction where was this
happening it on the internet so no I
know but like where what do you mean
forums chat exactly forum through all
these blogs you know it's very HP
Lovecraft things your nas to know it's
especially it was it was blogs not
really Twitter at the time and Facebook
groups those are the big ones back then
so this would have been about like 2013
mm-hm 2012 okay so now some of this
stuff starts bubbling up right and you
start seeing these communities that sort
of don't really align but have some
weird touch points and what do you make
of those times and but what I knew from
my you know I'm a big pop culture person
obviously and I knew how culture
develops which is it starts at the
fringe with the weirdos and then the
edgy people the cool people like hey
have you heard about this thing then it
becomes more mainstream and then like
kind of the Nerds get it then the
corporation's appropriated and kind of
tone it down right so all the
intellectual momentum I saw on the right
was a result of this stuff these are the
people talking ideas both nefariously
and positively these are the ones asking
the big questions and basically the
radical questions and one of the big
differences between conservatives and
you right is this conservatives take
what is given and this isn't a slight
against conservatives and regard it as a
right basically what we have how do we
fix it the new right often has a more
radical approach meaning just because
something exists doesn't mean it can't
be destroyed completely and started from
scratch so these are two different
approaches and we see it regarding the
press I got into an argument with Sean
Davis who writes for the Federalists and
his whole point is that you know the
media they're all they're they're all
dumb and my point is no no
these people are very very bright and if
they're all making the same mistake in
the same exact way that is not a
function as to pity stupid people aren't
all going to agree this is a function of
something more nefarious so that so it's
not a bug it's a feature correct because
they do have a certain specific agenda
and everyone has a certain specific
agenda so this is a big separation
between conserves and your right is this
you know part of society salvageable or
is it inherently impure and and and
beyond redemption
so when Trump was being elected I had
Eric Weinstein sitting in that seat and
what I said to him was what most people
seem to want is a panther in a china
shop we know something's wrong with the
system but we don't want to blow up the
system we want to Panther to walk in
there and knock something off with its
tail and bang one thing off with its
head now then close the door behind it
and well you know a couple things will
have broken but we'll be ok but there's
no such metaphor as a panther editor
it's a bull in a china yeah but you just
can't get it I sense that a lot of what
you're talking about is these people
want the ball in the chain no these
people want a bomb in a touch on the
chef they want the china shop to be
destroyed and the phrase china shop is
pretty apps here because it's talking
about you know foreign influence in
America and that's China's not their big
villain specifically but basically the
idea like this store needs to be torn
down we're not breaking some dishes this
is we're way past the point of breaking
some dishes but they want to blow up the
whole store it's not just about break-in
the China that's in this store they
actually want the entire structure and
something and salted the earth yeah
to make sure nothing can be built there
good but stop so where where do you fall
on that because I sense there is this
weird thing of there's this weird thing
on both the left and the right the left
seems to really want to destroy the
whole thing too in a weird way but then
you're you're talking about people on
the new right that want to destroy the
whole thing they want to destroy it for
different reasons but what do you think
the left wants to destroy the left wants
to destroy capitalism and they want to
destroy the basic way our democracy has
functioned and things like that I don't
I don't know that they want to destroy
capitalist so much they think of it as
something that can milk and harness
Bernie even Bernie you know has some you
know vaguely positive things to say
about capitalism but and I don't know
that they would ever admit well I think
it's a slow it's a slow slope to get
there you don't just come out with
anyone and say you
destroy capitalism you just keep right
but undermining it over election after
all is a is the new right is saying yes
we want to destroy this chapter 4 of
this book is called the case against
democracy so in this scene there is a
huge question of how is it that
democracy is inherently good let alone
inherently legitimate so lay out a case
sure so the best that you know people
say that communism works in theory not
in practice right well that doesn't mean
anything because everything works in
theory
practice is how you figure out something
actually works democracy is one of the
few things that doesn't even work in
theory and here's why if you have with
they talk about voter turnout being a
good thing well at what point does it
become legitimate if seventy percent of
people vote they can speak for the
thirty percent who don't vote what if
it's 40 percent vote and sixty percent
don't at what point is it that you can
say this group of the population can
dominate this other group who haven't
voted that's one example but in more
technical terms the purest I use an
example in this book called the
Machiavelli it's the purest example our
of democracy is the town hall you have a
bunch of people everyone's there to kind
of speak their mind put their point of
view across even in Town Hall you're
gonna have to have limits on time you're
gonna have an agenda what issues were
going to discuss so even in the most
democratic system moment you're going to
have an elite setting the rules and
boundaries so one of the ideas behind
the new right is this theory of this
old-school theory a hundred years ago
called the circulation the elites
meaning Hillary Clinton will always have
more in common with george w bush than
she will have with the janitor and you
can't get rid of an elite so much as
replace it with another elite mmm-hmm so
this is a little bit of the way a game
of thrones ended sort of i i'm not i
okay okay there's a funny moment at the
end where they're trying to figure out
how to rule them in the future and one
of the guys says well what about
democracy let the people vote and
there's a moment where you're like oh
are they gonna end with democracy and
then everyone laughs well is it there
was another new right moment early on
because didn't some person hold up like
a PCB a piece of paper that says you
promised and they basically ripped and
laughed right so this idea of the
constitution is somehow going to start
working and save us is another thing
that they're very skeptical of so what
what are you politically if you had to
give yourself I am label sure I'm an
anarchist without adjectives an anarchy
without adjectives sir explain the
adjective part well me
there's different schools of anarchism
yeah and I'm Mork
there's anarcho-capitalism there's
anarcho-syndicalism anarcho-communism I
like it all my point is essentially is
that government is not legitimate it
cannot be made legitimate and you have
to start with that recognition now some
people think ok if you take away
government everyone's going to be equal
you're gonna wage equality some people
think ok it's gonna be hyper
capitalistic sure I'm a lot more
comfortable defending Anarchy than I am
defending capitalism or communism or
syndicalism so I think most people here
anarchist and they just think well I
mean I say this all the time it's just
you want to end up in Mad Max you just
want sort of warring factions constantly
trying to take each other out and that
there is no sort of social cohesion
there's no way to build big projects and
things like that because we don't have
something that's sort of bringing us all
together that the government kind of
sucky I mean a lot of people think this
it's kind of sucky but it's the best we
got it's the best criticisms of
anarchism are actually descriptions of
the status quo meaning what you're
describing is the status quo you have
governments who are trying to take each
other out china has you know hacked our
systems russia you know is interfering
our elections so other right now nations
have a state of anarchy with regard to
each other to some extent what anarchism
would do would provide more security
because you wouldn't have to have a
government monopoly the idea that you
need the government to kind of build a
big project is really not necessarily
true and if anything the government is
probably the biggest hindrance towards
people working together because they
have to run things through some
bureaucrat who has no accountability
okay but wait I want to back up before
we go to down that road so just break
down a couple of these other groups that
were sort of in this trolling community
and can you just explain like for
someone of a certain age that really
doesn't even under that's not on Twitter
and they're not on 4chan or wherever
else is going on or discord sure like
what is actually going on with the
trolls like what is the goal of the coup
the older people actually no trolling
quite well because the example I used in
the book the first troll was Andy
Kaufman so Andy Kaufman right he was the
great troll of all great trouble of all
time he was on taxi as ladka which is
not what
proudest of and he would do things like
he had this character called Tony
Clifton who was basically as like a
lounge singer and a pink salmon blazer
and he comes out and sing terribly and
just berate the audience and and one
most trolling moment is he had this he
was performing I think in Atlantic City
and he says oh you know my wife died a
few years ago when I look at my
daughter's eyes I see my wife come on
out here honey and she sits on his left
and they sing and her voice cracks and
he slaps her across the face and he goes
what the hell you're doing her and the
audience is booing and he goes don't
don't boo you're just making her cry
more well not only wasn't his daughter
it wasn't even a child as an actress so
trolling correctly is forcing a party
exploiting a party's weaknesses in order
to turn them into an unwitting performer
so other examples of this there was a
little kid a little autistic kid was on
The Late Show in the UK or Ireland and
they asked him hey what do you want to
do Huey Huey what he want to do when you
grow up and he goes I want to fly planes
into buildings and the guy goes what
because I want to fly planes to
skyscrapers he's like okay if you can't
do that what would you want to do I'll
move to Iraq and be a terrorist now it's
this little ten-year-old boy and the
host now doesn't know what to do I just
put on the spot that is trolling now
trolling is often used on the Internet
to be like being a jerk that's not to me
a definition of trolling there's plenty
of words for that and just going to
someone saying you know you're this or
you're that that's not clever you're
holding is an art so troll okay so how
is it the Trump understood this do you
think because this is where people say
well he's just an idiot he just says
whatever he wants there's no filter that
out there and it's like if that really
is the truth if that really is the truth
then everyone else must be hyper idiot
you know you mean like I just can't
assess possible which let me give it a
great example of Trump trolling okay
again trolling meaning you're forcing
someone to become a performer by
exploiting their weaknesses which it
seems like now all the media has become
all of his enemies have become him to
take any position on anything is the
perfect example yeah for one year he's
yelling at Elizabeth Warren take a DNA
test take a DNA test take a DNA test she
takes it in secret doesn't even test for
Native American blood it says she's at
most 100,000 24th she releases it and
she goes ha mr. president I took the
test and you know what he goes who care
yeah so now she's made a fool of he is
not at all engaging with her and she's
left you can even hear the Curb Your
Enthusiasm isn't playing as she talks
and this woman has become a broken woman
as a consequence of his plowing her so
thoroughly what is it about him that you
think made him understand this how did
this guy understand this psychological
trick or whatever scenarios right Scott
Adams who I know you've had on yeah
Bruce describes the lucky Hitler
phenomenon right that somehow is just he
always manages to say that what he needs
to to upset people the other scenario is
like there's some kind of Rain Man thing
going on that he just sees people's
weaknesses he knows exactly what to say
and despite him themselves they lose
their minds another example this was I
think was pixelated boat there's some
Twitter account and they made this fake
screenshot from Michael Wolf's book fire
in fury about how Trump watches TV all
the time
and the staff at the White House made
something called the guerrilla Channel
and he talks to the guerrillas on TV and
he says oh that guerrillas good and
people and he was clearly a Joe it was
no joke people repeated this like oh my
gosh Trump is so dumb he talks to
television like wait a minute you could
think he's as dumb as you want you're
telling me this man who's 70 who's had a
TV show doesn't understand that you
can't talk to guerrillas on a screen but
that is the level that he's driven them
to so it's hilarious to watch and it's
beautiful from the anarchist perspective
because he's diligent izing the
political process and the presidency so
the reverence that people have for the
presidency has deadly consequences
because it allows them to get away with
things like war and if you think the guy
in the Oval Office is a clown and that
clown is getting ready to send your kids
overseas to possibly die or possibly
kill people you're gonna be a lot more
skeptical god there's a lot there so you
think it's yeah only someone would write
a book about the other thing there's a
lot there so you think in an odd way his
behavior is D legitimizing the
presidency let's say the office of the
presidency or more broadly government in
general and you ultimately view that as
a good thing because you don't think
that really has legitimate power to
begin with right one of the big views of
the Murray Rothbard school is that the
two political parties are literally
all gangs and just like a gangster has
the nice rings and the suits they wear
their suits they go to the Senate but
these are at base murderers who are
plotting you know fighting with each
other but it's in fighting so anytime
the mask is dropped and you realize
these people are stealing your money
they're trying to control your lives
they're causing massive you know harm
around the world often that's a good
thing what's the racial element that
comes out of all of this it's a cause
for as much as I get a lot of this and I
like a lot of the trolling the good
natured stuff that's really getting the
the people that I don't like to flip
their lids like I love all that stuff
sure and then there's this other piece
of it that sees that strikes me as it's
hard to tell that are they just
intentionally inflammatory do they
really believe this what kind of power
do these people have are they
coordinating all of that yes so Jared
Taylor is the head race realist right
these are the people who do racism as
the most important issue they all right
and I interviewed him for the for the
book I went to his house and you know
even he was confused and there was this
great moment he's got this very weird
accent he goes are you telling me these
people really believe this Hitler stuff
like he couldn't wrap it and I go yeah
and he goes the idea in this day and age
that hitlerism would be a model for
America is simply fantastic and I go you
mean crazy right he goes oh yes thank
you for the clarification so even in
that group though they're the racists
but he is you know Pro Jew then you have
the people who are full blown it what
does that mean
so they're the racist meaning there are
just people who just full-blown racism
there they just actually racist they
want people based on the color of skin
to have different laws or not be in this
country you're correct and they say if
you're not if you don't see that as the
most important issue you're blind
mm-hmm so I you know had to engage with
that writing this book then they're the
ones who everything's about the Jews the
Jews the Jews you know I when I was in
Charlottesville I saw everything
happening I couldn't go to all the
events because my contact was told don't
bring the Jew to the party I was not
wearing the blazer but so there is this
whole subculture and they disagree with
themselves and it was important for me
to engage with them and express what
their point
and show how they're wrong because what
happens is when you drive people to the
margin it's like telling and especially
we deal with young males it's like when
you tell kids if you smoke the principal
your parents and everyone's gonna get
upset and then you can't get a pom off
fast enough so that's the same thing
here it's like if you talk to these
people and say certain things people you
hate are gonna get upset
it's like sign me up so the point I make
in this book is you take one red pill
not the whole bottle because once they
realize that the corporate press is
often dishonest and has an agenda they
fall down this rabbit hole and unless
someone grabs him by the collar and say
yeah you don't have to go all the way we
can stop right here
they're often lost so this is you would
argue then the reason why censoring
these people and suspending people on
Twitter and booting people on Facebook
on the rest of it is actually the worst
possible thing that you could do I don't
know you become you just feeding it I
don't know if it's the worst but if
they're gonna say there is an elite
agenda designed to drive us underground
and keep the truth from coming out now
they have evidence look we're being
blocked they don't want to hear the
truth
so that is and the fact that David Duke
for example is still on Twitter is very
curious to me and again with the
internet technology sir wait what do you
think that's about them well I think
David Duke is a very useful foil for the
left because when he endorses people at
keith Ellison real Hannam arts crickets
right but when he says something
positive about somebody else like oh my
god yeah yeah I don't think he likes
Trump too much miss Trump all the
trumped kids Merrick except for one
Mayer Jews so you know it's it's a he's
not that fond of the president
everything's about Israel David Duke and
I told him once on Twitter so that was a
fun moment you took out the Duke like I
don't know if I know I didn't he's still
there and that's the problem
like why is David Duke there while
people like Laura Loomer art I think
that is a very odd situation and you
would say that really is just because of
the power dynamic within Twitter or
within something bigger than that I
can't speak to why I'm not inside Jack's
mind Jack Dorsey's mind yeah I do think
there's something here that's not adding
up and I think the more transparency the
better and I think Jack and some level
would agree with that yeah what's your
position on
to do with the tech companies at this
point related to all of this in the
censorship and everything I think the
solution is going to be just like back
in the day we had OkCupid and now you
have tinder and and all these other
sites and they separate out you're going
there's no reason everyone has to be in
one site so the more if Twitter wants to
say we're a site for progressive ideas
they have that right and that's
perfectly fine they're going to lose a
huge market share because when you drive
out fringe ideas where they're evil
fringe you're also going to be driving
up the good fringe idea and that's where
innovation happens so you if you're
gonna have this bourgeois middle of the
road
I don't want weirdness you're going to
lose the interesting people also so this
is a very big double-edged sword so then
why hasn't this problem been fixed
there's enough people frustrated with it
all over the political map good old
classical liberals are just as
frustrated as perhaps more nefarious
characters yeah but nobody has solved
this but your frustration might be a
feature because they say look we're
obviously doing things right we've got
Dave Rubin upset so there if we live in
a culture that's heavily dominated by
the progressive ideology so for them if
they are getting certain people upset
they can say hey we're doing our job
right the euphemism they currently uses
the quality of the conversation hmm
right so I mean this is the most Elian
thing ever like you're gonna be judging
quality so that's it's it's it's a very
it's very and which is a very different
thing from free speech which is messy
and ugly and and and you know often
reprehensible mm-hmm how do you think
that the new right then is supposed I
know you don't like boundaries and you
don't like gatekeeping in any of those
things but how do you think you think
how do you like it I like gates I'm not
an inclusion aspersion I'm very much for
freedom of association if I don't want
to talk to someone I'm not black people
liberally but all right so but you know
in a wider group outside of just what's
happening in your mind yeah your
interactions with people how do you
think that this new sort of group of
people that are all over the map
politically right how do they do how do
they keep the fringe people the truly
bad people out of the way this seems to
be the biggest issue yes that nobody
solving the because technology has made
it it used to be you had three net
right ABC NBC CBS and between the three
of them you get the news then Drudge
came along I was talking about in the
book and the networks are like he's not
legitimate he's not legit when he's not
legitimate he breaks one of the biggest
stories of all time Monica Lewinsky they
didn't know what to do he's still he's
not legit reason Jim it's like he broke
news who are you to say he's now Jimin
so this this Orthodox idea of legitimacy
has no inherent meaning other than
tribalism right so once you have
technology and thanks to Twitter
Facebook whatever everyone has their own
mic and there are more and more mics
being built every day I don't see how
you're gonna be able to put that genie
back in the bottle so you just have to
let it be then
you'd say there's just no option it just
is correct and you have to engage with
bad ideas if you want to defuse them
because you're not thanks to technology
you're not gonna be able to censor
anyone let me give you another example I
have this in the book let's suppose this
like 1990 right and you're having an
argument censoring books and one guys
like we need to censor books like mine
calm it has bad consequence someone else
like no you'd hear free speech I come
from 2019 teleport back in time and I
say look someday you're going to be able
to copy a book infinitely at no cost you
press one button you send it anywhere on
earth at the speed of light for free
I would sound like a lunatic but that is
the status quo oh and also you could you
be a magic word no but ordinary to the
password okay crazy person yes status
quo and technology is only going to
increase more and more and more to
empower the individual at the expense of
big conglomerates it becomes cheaper and
cheaper to make your voice heard back in
the day you'd have to be like you don't
like it make your own network well you
did now it's gonna be I mean it except
we're still using their pipes I'm still
depend right at least for the moment on
correct
there's no there's a great book called
the goal and the point of this book is
what's a goal there was to go the
business and he says to make money so
how you do this is you look at the
pipeline from conception to production
and you look at what's slowing up your
profits so maybe you're having shipping
boxes maybe you're not producing enough
bottles maybe you have too much where
inventory so you gotta have more
marketing maybe YouTube's not sending
your videos out to your subscribers
right so you look at what the issue is
the bottleneck you fix that once that's
fixed there's gonna be another worse
thing and you fix that so
Twitter in many ways is a rearguard
movement right now because people are
realizing it's paypal and it's the banks
that and it's the fact that there's
domain registrar's those are the next
three that people are going to build
alternatives to because that's where
their banks are shutting down accounts
right now and that's what's being
underreported so Twitter is kind of a
little bit of a distraction because
you'll always be able to make some rival
to Twitter banking and PayPal that's
what's something people have to look at
now and do you think the right people
are looking at it yeah I think in your
world er are people looking at it I
don't think this is an ideological thing
I think it's just some entrepreneur
who's sees a market opportunity be like
PayPal is being arbitrary and I can
compete with them on some level all it
takes is that one guy and then the
battle is won and then it's gonna be
another battle it's an asymptotic
situation so what are some of the
policies of the new if the new right
becomes takes over the conservative
movement or let's try to consider is the
enemy right so whatever that is that
whether they burn the thing down or were
they whether they infiltrate it or
whatever the people that care about
these ideas broadly that you're talking
about what does it actually look like
politically like what are the things
that they would be fighting for police
so this is what's hilarious is you have
a group whose United only by their
opposition's progressivism what do you
want to do they have no even close to
unanimity some want a military junta
like just martial law yeah some like me
not for me not for me okay thank you or
a good some want complete Liberty
meaning Anarchy some want a restriction
of the right to vote some want to
accelerate they want more leftism
because they think if you accelerate and
amplify the system is going to collapse
because of the inherent contradictions
and leftism so you have no consensus
whatsoever about what the next steps and
same thing with like for example they
think people think oh everyone in this
group likes Trump some of them loathe
Trump mm-hmm completely and unabashedly
and Coulter who I've talked about this
book she's come out very hard against
him and I think she called him a [ __ ]
or something like that what do you make
of her related to Trump it was like she
was huge Pro Trump but then he's not you
know he's not building the wall fast
enough for her or a couple of the other
things it's like some Coulter you
there's also some real politic involved
yeah
Colten used to be a real troll right she
knew how to say the exact right things
to upset people
now she's gotten much more serious and
ideological in her later books it's
interesting to see her relationship with
Trump I mean she said at one point she
thought America was like 90% no chance
now it's maybe 40% cuz at Trump's
election she's very 90% of her chance
what that Americas done we're done she
thought it was like we're over like I
was that chance today and she was like
okay maybe it's 40% that we're done
because Trump gotta like that I can't
really speak for her but she is a very
kind of interesting character and I
discussed her ID as a length because her
book audios America was probably the
most influential book of the 2016
election cycle that's the book where
Trump got the idea of they're sending
the rapists mm-hmm
who do you find you can debate with on
the other side of this so I get you can
you can be around people on the right
that you disagree on a lot of these
Sharron things and you don't come out of
the racist camp and all that stuff you
find that there are some good actors on
the left that you can engage with a lot
people like Glenn Greenwald Michael
Tracy Jimmy Dore I actually don't debate
because I'm not interested in persuasion
I'm just there to have fun and I think
debating is often a waste of time and
it's always a waste of time
I mean the cost/benefit so I don't
really do I've had a few people on my
show who are you know pretty far left no
Mikey Const was on I also did like
debating with conservatives because I
really disagree with them and since I'm
coming at them from this what's your
line on that conservatism is there it is
amiss progressivism driving the speed
limit mm-hmm so one of the things I
discuss in this book is National Review
my favorite paleontology magazine in the
late 90s they had this editorial
comparing the fight for gay rights to a
theoretical fight for necrophilia and
saying what's the difference between
fighting for two men to have sex with
each other as opposed to having sex with
the corpse and it was just a very
disturbing article but now the
conservative case for gay marriage so
what our principles are there that would
have you say that then and have you say
this now so it's disturbing them and the
hypocrisy is disturbing to this day as
well so you're you're more you care more
about the hypocrisy of it not you don't
care about gay marriage well I mean I
care about both I mean if you're going
to have a principle I would have more
respect for someone to be like gay
marriage is wrong because of the Bible
blah blah blah and stick to that as
opposed to I'm anti-gay then because I'm
a phony and now man see gay now cuz I'm
a phony you're you're bringing nothing
to the table yeah but I mean you protect
you specifically you don't care I do I
wouldn't care that you're married that's
well that's what I meant I mean you
don't care
I mean care in a negative sense oh of
court no no yeah I'm no absolutely
please marry whatever you want yeah
marry a corpse well no well you do have
limits only if they're good-looking only
if they're good-looking you can marry a
cool think things are gonna get as we
roll into 2020 because I think we're
still as crazy as possible hopefully and
here's something that I've called that
once I say no one can really kind of
deny it
historically the President or the
nominee hasn't really engaged with the
other party's primary process for the
first time in history a sitting
president is going to be live tweeting
the debates and the primary of the other
team and not only that it's not like
he's gonna comment like oh I disagree
with his economic plan he's lobbing
nukes in his trumpian style and none of
these 23 candidates are going to know
what to do
and none of their advisors who are
getting paid a lot of money social media
experts are going to have know what to
do there's no blueprint and the question
becomes is it a badge of honor that
Trump is clowning me does that make me
the strong candidate do I ignore him am
i above the fray like historically
people used to do like out my opponent
you know that kind of stuff so this is
going to be absolutely hilarious and you
want that hilarity the more chaos the
better politically yeah I don't want
people to be able to get together and
impose their will so what if you were
one of the 23 what would you do well as
someone that knows how to play the
trolling game that knows how to you know
throw the bombs back let's say what
would you do Trump so you're on stage
trumps you know doing his Twitter thing
you get offstage you see what's going on
what would you do or what would you take
if you were an adviser to one of these
people what would you do well I I know
you don't want to give away all your
resign I would never advise it but in
all seriousness what I would do is if
you look at when he was a Comedy Central
Roast and they asked him beforehand they
said what jokes can you make and can't
you make the only thing he wasn't
comfortable being joked about
was that he's not as rich as he wanted
as he claims he is so since that's his
line I would hit him with that line as
much as possible but at the same time
it's hard to troll someone who is that
you know hiroshi amano china shop I mean
he's easy there it is but I know Justin
Amash got him pretty good
mhm I think over the weekend with coming
out in favor of impeachment I think that
really ruffled his feathers
what would on the bono you know what it
is this is what I would hit him with I
would say you bragged during the
campaign that you would hire the best
and smartest people how come all these
people are resigning you know and and
hit him with that his big core
competency alleged core competency how
confident do you think he is or is it
I actually forgetting the the tactic the
trolling tactic interpreter is that
confident as being present competence
being present it's hard to tell because
there's I've that theory that it
probably is not crazy that when you'd
become present they sit you down they're
like all right this is what you can do
and this is what you can't do the fact
that Obama was droning everyone all the
time it seems like it's out of his you
know peace Nick background or it could
be that you know he was a closet you
know hawk at the whole time we don't
know I don't think any of us really know
what it's like to be president the fact
that he hasn't gotten a lot of his big
promises through is kind of a big deal
the fact that he has taken on
unprecedented opposition and his head is
still you know being held high his
approval ratings are still relatively
high I mean that's a bit of an
accomplishment so since you wrote a book
on a North Korea yeah and there's been a
little I think last time I had you on
maybe they were in the beginnings of
summer those discussions where we at
with North Korea right I am so North
Korea has this secret weapon which
causes everyone on earth to have amnesia
and what happens is North Korea goes
through these cycles its night follows
day which is there'll be war mongers
we're gonna nuke America we're gonna
kill everyone blah blah and then six
months later we want peace please work
with us please work with us and they've
just gone back to the war cycle and
everyone's like oh my god we've never
heard this for North Korea had put
sentence president Trump to death they
were threatening to new Guam and Alaska
and even previously that they were
threatened accosted so it's this is how
they this is this song oh come on
it so this is where they are right now I
am very hopeful the thing I'm very happy
with with President Trump is that North
Korea is now on the front pages because
we need to engage with this most evil
country and I was on Fox and Friends
first or a while ago and they said what
is your big concern with the summit and
I said the continuing enslavement of the
North Korean people so that whenever
you're looking at this issue always ask
in my view what does this mean for these
20 million hostages who are being kept
enslaved by this evil government that
starved its population on purpose during
the 90s and killed 1 to 2 million people
that's not funny yeah so do you think
the Trump is sort of the perfect person
for this that as North Korea vacillates
back and forth with all this rhetoric
that Trump can actually match them at
that and that might be the thing that
kind of allows a daytime I don't know
about perfect but I you have to have
hope for these people especially I mean
not to sound whatever once you've been
there and you've seen people there
everyone I met in North Korea is still
there like every single person I saw on
the street every kid every grandma and
it messes with their head cuz this is
what 2012 think how much your life has
changed in this way Michelle think how
much mine has and none of theirs has I
still see my guide you know pictures of
her on Instagram and she's still trapped
and she's like a millionaire there but
she's still trapped in that prison with
those gilded bars so it's very
disturbing how does an anarchist care
about foreign policy well because this
the guy says the government's the enemy
this is the most evil government on
earth it's a pretty easy soldier ISM
interesting you don't really think about
that though I mean generally when people
think of a more libertarian view of the
world it's like no just let everybody do
whatever the hell they want well I'm not
gonna let the government do whatever the
hell they want to these people yeah I
mean and that's the other thing like we
have it so even though it's not your
government these are human beings and
you know being born in the Soviet Union
being Jewish these were two chances my
family could have been sent to
concentration camp so the fact that we
have concentration camps right now that
you could see them on Google Earth you
know a high school always talked about
how the Holocaust happened how that all
happened something similar happened in
the 90s in North Korea against its own
population so
this is something that maybe other
people don't care but for me it's kind
of like there but for the grace of God
go I when I met the guy that I had she
had the same haircut my mom had in like
1982 which is like cutting edge for
North Korea but it's just looking at
like a sliding doors thing and it's like
holy crap I could have been born here
and instead of sitting here in my really
Wonka costume you know who knows what
would have happened to me what do you
think's gonna happen to the traditional
conservatives Oh God
is it absolutely over because they can't
withstand what's coming on both sides at
this point I don't see how they come
back because I don't they didn't bring
that much to the table to begin with as
opposed to like give it socking to the
left and now Trump is talking to the
left more than anyone else has I'm gonna
be talking to Ben damage you know you
know not that long from the Federalists
I'm very curious to hear his take on
this book and this thesis because
because he's someone that is more of a
traditional he's a hardcore pure
conservative mutual respect I like him a
lot but I don't see how they regain this
party especially because if one of the
big issues with conservatism and maybe
republicanism as young people young
people are going to be drawn to humor
and edginess and memes and they're not
going to be drawn to kind of like hey
remember Reagan you know Reagan's great
he ended the Cold War but this is not
going to be a selling point for your
movement and also that I think young
people are also drawn to aggression and
kind of flipping over tables and that's
what the new right does offer them are
there political leaders outside of
however much Trump is involved in this
or there's some other people that you
like I know that's the weird thing it's
like you don't want a political leader
per se because you don't want to be
personally who I like yeah or that you
think can sort of grab some of these
pieces and do something good in your
estimation
uh I can't I I'm sure there are Tulsi
Gabbard I like anyone who brings more of
the anti-war message mm-hmm honey you
wrote a book called the new right and
you're picking a candidate who's running
as a Democrat sure anti-war Democrat but
I interesting I would love it if there
was a complete consensus in Washington
that war is a last resort and an
absolute nightmare that is my goal so I
just like we agree that slay
every is a non-starter you're like sure
I'll get the argument that maybe we have
to go to war but the fact that we can be
so glim about it and be like oh yeah
we're just gonna here's another example
do you think that we've crossed a little
bit of a threshold when it comes to war
I mean I feel like the mistakes of Iraq
and nobody knows why the hell were in
Afghanistan still Trump is not beating
war drums you know there's there's stuff
about there's always this over-the-top
rhetoric related to Iran but I said I
don't sense this is a guy that wants to
just say I think he's actually very
against the bull of these
nation-building the bloodlust of the
establishment which I include the
corporate press cannot be overstated
when 2016 Trump's the nominee we heard
it every single day he's crazy he's
gonna give us two World War three he's
gonna get pissed off at a tweet from
China and press the nuclear button
remember we heard this all the time
Carly Fiorina got asked this in the
second debate the first question do you
trust press and Trump with his finger in
the nuclear button and now China has
hacked our systems Russia has you know
tried to interfere with their elections
and the press is constantly saying do
something about it do something about do
something that do something about
Venezuela so the fact that he's not
getting us into World War three is not
being used as a slide against him by the
same people who regarded that as a
problem when he was a nominee hmm it's
horrific and this has been a long time
coming how much debt since uh the we
talked about yellow journalism in high
school remember
the spanish-american war and then they
pretend it went away it didn't go away
the same press wants if it bleeds it
leads they can't wait to get us into
another engagement it's it's disgraceful
what happened what has happened with the
press then and I mean this in terms of
cable news mainstream news network news
I mean this box of polls sure the battle
speed all the battle is won when the
average corporate journalist is regarded
with the exact same way as the average
tobacco executive they have a job
they're promoting their product their
product is cancerous and deadly they're
often bright people they're often good
people but be aware of what it is that
they're selling you so how do we find
some people to trust in the mix of all
this and in this big mess trust trust
but verify
I mean I'll use the Reagan I mean trust
is I'm not interested in trusting people
omission in trusting ideas
and creating mechanisms that people
can't enforce their wills that trust
won't be necessary like I don't need to
trust like eBay right I don't need to
trust that other guy is gonna be
honorable because they have their
different systems I can get my money
refund and so and so forth so there's no
reason for me to have a political leader
trust because systemically he's going to
betrayed me at some point or another god
there's a lot here malice thank you take
me somewhere else altogether what do you
mean where else do you want to go in
this conversation right now
well I I mean I got a million things
rattling here yeah doesn't it bother you
I one of the things I defend in this
book is dark humor and here's the let's
fly back to North Korea yeah I knew a
refugee and he said so when people say
that's not funny right it's this
Puritanism HL Mencken said Puritanism is
the idea that someone somewhere is happy
right
I knew this refugee North Korean refugee
and he went to high school here and he's
talking his friends and they go hey
remember when we were kids we had
Pokemon and he goes yeah except instead
of Pokemon I watched my dad start to
death now are you going to tell him
that's not a right right are you do you
know what it's like the ones coping
mechanism one hungry starve to death and
it's your own dad we can never wrap our
heads around this so for you to tell him
that kind of joke is not appropriate how
dare you Bonnie McFarlane a great
comedian was roasting Jim Norton and she
said your show is so unlistenable I'd
rather hear my daughter drowned
now that's very dark but are you telling
me she doesn't love her daughter are you
telling me she's not a tell a joke so
the metaphor I use when people say a
certain subject is not appropriate for
humor I say it's like flower FL o FL oh
you are is flower of food well no one
eats flower but everyone eats it when
it's processed and baked right so same
thing with jokes then this darker the
subject the harder it is to make it
palatable and I have examples of you
know they made me cut one joke but I
have examples of all sorts of you know
subjects that are supposed to be off
limits and maybe you personally don't
find it funny if someone's been
assaulted and they're like you know
these kind of jokes set me off that's
there but the idea that no one yeah
should find that funny is nothing well
it's also stealing something that's very
human is that we use humorous comedy is
tragedy plus time we use humor to be
able to look back
on the past I mean if Mel Brooks
couldn't have made fun of Hitler
couldn't have made fun of maracas that
was that was actually healing for I'm
sure for him personally but for millions
of other people but the establishment
which gets by on legitimacy and quality
conversation it cannot abide that court
jester laughing at them is do you think
that's why they took out the aoc parody
down on twitter cuz it was really
freaking good they took out a lot of
parody accounts and it's strange all
those Trump parody accounts are still up
and and the parrot and staring live
which is that right and they're great do
it make you should be making upon the
president but you're not saying Senate
life is great are you why not sure I
pretty crappy I haven't watched anyone
yeah no I mean I've been watching
fifteen years but every time I see a ten
second clip it's like it's basic physics
basically as good as the Gene Wilder
Willy Wonka movie so if they call not my
friend
yeah I'm just kidding there's a callback
it's just the most ludicrous thing I've
ever heard in my entire life someone who
I love you're outside the box thinking
and yet that's bizarre
the point is the humor is if you it's
this it's a Jewish thing it's this
Jewish thing of laughing to keep from
crying and it's a very waspy thing you
know it's like oh you know you don't
make the kind of jokes at the dinner
table and just because something isn't
for someone doesn't mean it's not for no
one and one of the elements of the
Evangelic ileft
is the idea of universalism everything
has to be inclusive everything has to be
for everyone and my answer is no not
everything has to be for everyone and
that's okay not everyone is luck in my
house not everyone's gonna enjoy this
book and you know what if you don't
think I'm interesting or funny or smart
I wish you nothing but goodwill
this is a big world go live your best
life do you think that it doesn't make
sense that or does it deeply that
they're obsessed with our differences
they're obsessed with our skin color
differences in our sexuality and our
gender differences I mean that is the
entire thrust of everything that they're
giving us and yet they're also the ones
that want us to be exactly the same well
is that because is that a feature or a
bug actually I don't know if it's a
feature a bug it certainly works for
them to some extent because what you
know kind of evangelical progressivism
gives people is a sense of certainty and
it also gives them a sense of being
saved right so once I recognize the
pervasiveness of wreck of racism
kind of been initiated into the
mysteries of this faith and therefore
since I'm inherently good now I'm in a
position to condemn heretics and sinners
and if necessary wipe them off the face
of the earth so they they want us to be
the same in terms of being saved but
they don't want us to be necessarily
save in terms of a literalist I don't
know that I've ever heard you talk about
this specifically but how much of what
do you think is going on with the
evangelical left as you just described
them is just a disconnect from fate oh I
think it's a degeneration of the social
gospel so if I trace this so
conservatives you know when I talk to
them they're like oh they admit that the
Left controls culture and media and
Hollywood and thing and things like that
and you say what how did this happen and
they're like we have to have our own
version I go how did this happen like oh
it used to be and like when when it was
the 1930s when literal confidence are
running Hollywood or when Woodrow Wilson
is playing Birth of a Nation at the
White House FDR has so many Democrats
that they have to sit on the Republican
side the seats in Congress it makes no
sense you're saying it's not that they
lost control they never had control
correct it's always been and there's a
reason because leftism lends itself to
innovation and creativity because one of
the aspects of leftism is liking what's
new' liking what's innovative this is
psychological thing and there's nothing
wrong with being conservative saying I
don't like new stuff I like things the
same that's if that's fine for you but
that's going to be a huge disadvantage
when you're trying to attract people who
are artistically minded because they're
gonna be drawn to those who are maybe
not overly openly minded right because
it sounds good I'm for progress
everyone's for progress but it depends
what you're progressing to correct it is
the rub
so how conservatives how let the Left
controls culture and built it is one of
the big themes of this book and it's I
think filling in a big hole on the right
because conservatives really don't know
and here's another example conserves you
remember back in the 90s Jon Stewart you
know what the 2000 excuse me was running
the show and the answer was let's have a
conservative Daily Show
that's not creativity that's just
mirroring what someone else has built as
opposed to people like I would say like
Rush Limbaugh and Roger Ailes rush
limbaugh invented basically talk radio
made it what it was Roger Ailes was told
we want you to compete with CNN he goes
no no I'm going to destroy CNN and CNN
was all news and he made it this news
entertainment opinion thing
and then CNN followed suit so those are
two examples of the right actually
creating something kind of so generis
you think we ever get to something that
feels a little more stable again the
night worth it right now
I think stability politically means
oppression and I think the stability of
like let's suppose the 50s and and this
is one things I'm hopeful with social
media
they were entire schools of thought that
were made invisible because they were
threatening to the social order and now
they have to pick people off one by one
instead of entire schools of thought and
that is progress in a good way what if
you were picked off I'm too charming no
I I mean I can be glitter I mean it suck
it would suck that what would you do I
mean because I that's what a lot of
people are thinking it's like you know
we've seen enough of the names that
we've mentioned throughout this show get
picked off and get suspended and get
banned it's not that there are best
buddies or anything but there were
everyone's sort of in the same sort of
circles at some level again coming from
that Soviet background I know that idea
of like it could be you tomorrow it's
not it's always that random because that
way you keep everyone scared can you
dive into that a little bit more sure so
one of the techniques that the Soviets
did is it wouldn't be like the worst
people who would get picked off like
Darius said find me the man I'll find
you the crime so Stalin and I do not
think we're in a Stalinist Society I'm
just using this as a metaphor a very
loose metaphor I just really want that
to be clear because I we got a ways to
go before that but the the principle to
keep a population kind of submissive is
it's not always the loudmouth you pick
the housewife or you pick this grandma
and then everyone knows you could be
next so you only got to take out like
three people and that one hundred are
going to basically fall in line and
because Twitter's rules are ambiguous
and it's seemingly at random and they
don't even give warning they could have
sat down that a or C account said these
three tweets are offensive delete them
yeah they're so even though he did
nothing wrong by that by the rules that
they supposedly put out there I mean he
labeled it a parity account that's the
main sure and many people have more than
one account and very and also if you're
want to be have this kind of public
square you know political conversation
once someone is a certain level of
stature who are you know kind of an
influencer it might be that jack has to
talk to them personally or there has to
be three checks before they're banned or
you could have warnings
I mean there's a lot of systems for
keeping people who are part of this
thriving conversation in place but
that's not what they want and that's
their right but this is something that
people should recognize so you would say
that the tech companies basically want
to keep us all in semi-darkness all the
time because that's the easiest way to I
don't know if it is easy but it seems to
be effective for them in terms of
because then you have self-censorship
right because you know I had this tweet
I don't remember what it was and I was
scared to put it up because I'm like
yeah any moment that I have Sauron can
fall on me and I'm booted yeah and I'm
sure you know this feeling very well I
think there YouTube stuff yeah no I know
it extremely well and it's like if I'm
even remotely close to where the cliff
is man things have shifted in a
seriously dangerous way look there will
be a certain amount of people that don't
want me talking to you there are a
certain amount of people that didn't
want me talking to discern a [ __ ] etc
etc and I have to figure out who it's
who I think it's okay to talk and I
talked about that in the book how is it
okay for Barbara Walters to sit down
with like Qaddafi who murdered so many
people Diane Sawyer with Charles Manson
I mean with a swastika on his forehead
not telling me the Diane Sawyer didn't
endorse all the views of Charles Manson
because that seems to be what they say
about if I sit down with someone I must
endorse all their boy it's amazing and
when they're like oh he follows this
person on Twitter it's like everyone
Falls the President and he's the Norse
it like when CNN places video is speech
does that mean they're they're endorsing
it so it's a very weird situation again
because they're legitimate your
unorthodox you're not legitimate you
don't have the same rights in a sense
that they do yeah well we talked about
it right before we started but you saw
the way medium and media matters went
after me because I was gonna have mayor
Pete on right and immediately when I had
him though yeah well so that's the thing
I you yeah what can you take that away I
mean you you know exactly how it works
like they can't like when Donald Trump
jr. took a tweet of mine and put it on
Instagram and four days I was spending
people off yeah basically it was like
well they can't get a Trump so they're
gonna get at me so if they can't so you
don't give a crap about media matters
I'm sure but they can sure get to Pete
because they'll have his ear and it
worked
apparently I mean think how sad and
depressing that is forget forget mayor
Pete coming in here and do
the show it's actually irrelevant I
would like that talk to the guy but that
asteroid strikes me as irrelevant it's
more that either he or his handlers are
willing to bow to the mob but that he
you know his people basically agree to
do an interview and then because Media
Matters HuffPo and Vox which the latter
two are supposed to be places of
journalism they are leveraging or trying
to influence a political candidate it's
the only reason a mayor of a indiana
town is in the running for the
presidency is because of HuffPo Media
Matters and Vox the idea this is a
platform for even Senate beggars belief
so of course he's gonna count out to the
people who put him in the position he is
this guy's no natural constituency he's
like 37 years old we got a big battle
ahead of us yeah and the important thing
is to have fun and enjoy life because
we're still free and we're still blessed
in this country and this is one of the
things I do disagree with with many
pockets than you right these people
think America is ruined
we're destroyed there's no hope and it
makes me very very sad because you go on
long and you find more creative people
doing awesome things than you can count
yeah and we definitely focus seemingly
we focus on the negative more but that
is one of the things that when I see you
on Twitter I'm like you are actually
having fun with this oh yeah and there
is a need this endless political
political it is ization yes did I say
yes you did yeah of everything it's
making people crazy and depressed one of
the things I really hate about the left
and a certain kind of the left is the
idea that the personal is the political
and to me if I disagree with someone
politically that this would have any
ramification on our friendship is so
profoundly disturbing I can't even begin
like if god forbid some of my family
dies and I have to look at my phone and
be like well I can't call this person
because they're a Bernie person what
kind of humans are what a twisted place
what's the place and even people who are
like regular Christians don't think of
these terms like I have good friends I'm
staying with a couple there they're
solid Christians if my mode something
having my family one of theirs I mean
you're Jewish this would never even
enter their heads not even in a million
years but it's like oh you're a trump
voter you're a Hillary voter I can't you
know whatever with you this is very very
tribal and disturb
to me have you figured out any ways to
deprogram some of these people yes humor
I think I think once you encourage
people to see the absurdity of their
position and also it's tailed him you
can let go you don't have to be so
ideological all the time life is
wonderful enjoy your life and you
shouldn't be depressed let's let's
suppose my pence if you're gay and Mike
Prince is president that might suck for
you but come on go to work and go to eho
go to Hamburger Mary's have fun I mean
this is not really a reflection of your
life because there will always be a
president that you hate so focus as much
as you can and this isn't a pretty
shocking message I'm living your life to
the fullest
that's it ma'am yeah I don't need to ask
you anything else that's it I think
let's get people regardless of where the
politics fall on any of this it's like
let's get people to realize it's still
pretty good and and don't get too caught
up in all the lunacy and just when I'm
trolling someone just retweet it and sit
back and laugh don't screw up my trolls
where do you get this jacket
I'm a noble Impa made it follow the
Willy Wonka of politics Michael malice
on the Twitter at Michael malice
[Music]